[Música]
olá tudo bem com vocês
é muita alegria com muita satisfação que
estou presente aqui hoje eu gostaria de
parabenizar cada um de vocês pela
escolha da presença
estamos vivendo hoje numa era da
consciência numa era da expansão da
consciência e certamente nessa nossa era
você já escutaram as frases célebres que
é o pensamento cria a sua realidade
o pensamento positivo atrás situações
positivas certo todos vocês já ouviram
essas frases
pois bem baseado nessas duas premissas
eu gostaria de trazer lhes algumas
reflexões como está sua saúde você é
feliz no amor você já encontrou a sua
plenitude profissional você faz
atividades que você ama com freqüência
você conhece lugares incríveis
todo ano se o pensamento cria nossa
realidade
a resposta para essas perguntas deveriam
ser positivas afirmativas e construtiva
certo mas não é bem isso que eu venho
vendo acompanhado ao longo desses quase
20 anos de consultório as pessoas têm
chegado cada vez mais ansiosas
depressivas sem estima um síndrome do
pânico com transtornos e é sobre
exatamente isso que eu quero falar com
vocês hoje aqui sobre como criar a nossa
realidade e como funciona a nossa mente
em 1998 quando eu iniciei o meu a minha
a psicologia no estágio supervisionado
eu escolhi iniciar pela psicologia
infantil por acreditar que é na infância
que está toda a base do desenvolvimento
e eu me lembro como se fosse agora que a
coisa que eu mais pedi que o universo
foi pode vir qualquer caso eu estava
sedenta pra começar - abuso sexual
infantil e adivinhem qual foi o meu
primeiro no caso abuso sexual infantil
justamente eu fiquei tão intrigada com
aquilo como que com tantas estudante de
psicologia com quantos casos para
atender eu fui atrás justamente aquele
que eu acreditava ter mais dificuldade
foi a partir daquele momento que eu
comecei a estudar a mente e como criar a
minha realidade porque eu falei eu estou
conseguindo entender essa tal da lei da
atração
a nossa mente ela todos os cientistas
são unânimes em dizer que nós não usamos
nem 10% da nossa capacidade mental
nosso cérebro tal como ele é hoje ele
demorou dez milhões de anos para chegar
nessa plenitude e nós não estamos
conseguindo usar uma ínfima parte deles
para você conseguir entender como
funciona a mente primeiro você precisa
entender os mecanismos da mente o nosso
funcionamento mental ele é dividido em
consciente e inconsciente ou
subconsciente o consciente é esse que
vocês estão aqui agora me olhando às
vezes jogando criticando o consciente e
responsável por dizer se é certo e
errado se é bom ou mau ele também é
responsável pelo planejamento e pela
memória de curto prazo talvez o que
vocês não saibam é que o nosso
consciente e responsável apenas por 10%
da nossa capacidade mental a gente fosse
fazer analogia do iceberg ele é como se
fosse aquela pontinha do iceberg
o que está submerso é a nossa mente
subconsciente ea nossa mente
subconsciente é a parte que eu sou mais
apaixonada é a minha área de estudo a
mente subconsciente ela tem um campo
imenso de possibilidades para você tem
ideia de da importância da mente
subconsciente é responsável pelos seus
batimentos cardíacos por sua respiração
pelo seu sono pela sua digestão pelas
nossas funções vitais mas não pára por
aí
a mente conseguir consciente ela também
é responsável pelos nossos hábitos e
crenças pela nossa memória de longo
prazo desde a sua vida intra-uterina até
agora todas as imagens estão catalogadas
na nossa mente consciente ou
subconsciente
não tem como você ter um pensamento sem
criar uma imagem
uma analogia que eu gosto muito de fazer
para que você consiga entender como
interage a mente consciente e
inconsciente é a analogia do jardim e do
jardineiro sendo que o jardim somos nós
novamente com se desculpa o jardim eo
jardineiro somos nós nossa mente
consciente e o jardim é a nossa mente
subconsciente
durante todo o dia você está plantando
sementes de pensamentos no seu
subconsciente
mesmo que você não saiba e mesmo que
você não queira não tem como a gente
pensar ou falar sem criar uma imagem
o nosso consciente ele é responsável
pelo pensamento você pensa você cria uma
imagem essa imagem vai sendo levada para
o nosso subconsciente a freqüência
dessas imagens do subconsciente forma o
nosso padrão de comportamento é bom
pensar o seguinte se eu falo que uma
criança não suba na cadeira não fale
alto a imagem que foi levada para a
cabeça da criança foi a imagem além do
não ela consegue conscientemente
entender que não é para subir na cadeira
que não é pela falar alto mas não é uma
negativa simples quer ver
não pense num fusca azul e aí foi quando
eu percebi a onde estava o meu erro
quando no meu estágio supervisionado e
pediu que eu não queria anos voltar
analogia do jardim do jardineiro quando
você planta uma semente pode ser uma
linda flor ou uma erva daninha ambas não
dá
o jardim não escolhe o que vai crescer
quem escolhe é você é a sua mente
consciente e eu quero que você analise
como que você tem levado essas imagens
para o seu subconsciente o meu estágio
supervisionado o maior aprendizado foi
que na mesma caixinha que estão os meus
sonhos estão os meus medos ea partir
daquele momento eu nunca mais pediu que
eu temia e sempre ordenei aquilo que eu
quero o nosso subconsciente ele não
questiona ele não sabe se é bom ou ruim
pra mim ele não sabe o que é certo e
errado por isso a maneira certa de
agente coordenar o nosso
subconsciente é falar de forma
afirmativa imperativa é como um comando
eu não peço eu mando então quando vou
falar com a criança que eu tenho que
falar
calça e sapato dança da cadeira fale
baixo ou não a gente não vai interpretar
eu espero que essa analogia seja o
suficiente para cair a ficha pra que
vocês consigam ligar índice o observador
internamente de vocês e comecem a
selecionar melhor os pensamentos porque
é assim que funciona a mente a nossa
mente funciona através de imagens
eu vou dar quatro dicas pra vocês de
como criar uma realidade mais produtiva
mais benéfica
a primeira dica é sair da dualidade no
livro curso milagres
eles nos explicam que nós estamos
vivendo numa dimensão aonde é uma
dimensão do ao débito e crédito feliz
triste sozinho acompanhado medo e amor
não tem como o tempo todo a gente está
oscilando as nossas emoções e nós somos
muito influenciados pelo nosso meio
externo pelo nosso meio ambiente e hoje
nessa era a coisa que mais nos
influencia é a tela
na minha época televisão hoje a tela é
porque a tela está espalhado em tudo
quanto é lugar
se você for reparar muito dados dos
telejornais das séries que a gente
assiste das novelas dos programas de
televisão muitas imagens já vem pronta
já chegou a infiltrar direto nós no
nosso subconsciente e muitas das imagens
são o que são imagens de violência são
imagens de pânico são imagens de
traições são imagens de desgraça quando
você está com a sua mente consciente
desperta você consegue não permitir com
que isso infiltre na sua mente mas a
gente está só reprogramando a essas
imagens ea gente não está selecionando
essas imagens sair da atualidade pode
ser um grande desafio é verdade porque
essa dimensão é de 6
da atualidade mas a partir do momento
que você se conecta e consegue estar
consciente dessas imagens você consegue
filtrar e consegue dominar suas emoções
e não ser dominado por elas já que a
gente está falando de negatividade
a segunda dica é reverter os pensamentos
negativos em pensamentos positivos
lembro que descontei que o nosso
consciente ele é crítico ele é jogador
então por exemplo se você vai fechar um
grande negócio o primeiro pensamento que
a sua mente consciente vai te dar é você
pode falir
você confia nessa pessoa que está
fazendo um negócio e isso é saudável
porque a omissão da nossa mente com
consciente é que a gente não saia da
zona de conforto é que a gente fique
parado realmente ele é uma pessoa que
está consciente ela vai olhar para esse
pensamento ela vai agradecer porque o
pensamento negativo se você remodela na
sua mente você vai ver que ele te ensina
muito quando eu tenho um pensamento
negativo que ele está me mostrando onde
está o meu medo a onde está a minha
sombra
só que o grande lance é eu não deixar
ele raiza eu vou olhar para esse
pensamento eu vou agradecer por ele está
vindo na minha tela mental e
automaticamente eu vou substituí lo eu
sou uma boa empreendedora eu sou um ímã
para o dinheiro eu atraio trocas
verdadeiras
aí eu consigo substituir na minha tela
mental o pensamento negativo a criança
até os 67 anos de idade ela não tenha
informado a sua mente consciente é puro
em consciente por isso é muito fácil da
criança acreditar no papai noel
coelhinho da páscoa no bicho papão
a partir do momento que você fala uma
coisa pra criança ela assume como
verdade e hoje muitos de nós temos
crenças negativas se eu escutei na minha
infância é preguiçosa a é muito lenta
este é chata pronto eu não tive um crivo
eu não consegui ver se aquilo era certo
ou errado eu acredito fielmente que eu
sou aquilo mas eu tenho uma boa notícia
para vocês porque o joseph murphy que é
um grande estudioso da mente humana ele
ensinou a reprogramar
nosso inconsciente mas pra isso a gente
vai precisar de duas coisas disciplina e
foco porque porque se você substitui o
que você tem de negativo vou dar um
exemplo que me veio agora por exemplo
você se acha tímida ou você se acha
ansiosa
então eu sei que eu sou isso como ele
vai reprogramar nossa mente durante três
vezes por dia eu vou afirmar o contrário
disso da ansiedade por exemplo a sua
serena eu sou sábia da timidez
eu sou comunicativa eu sou expansiva
se você consegue gravar isso por três
vezes na sua tela mental por 60 dias
consecutivos
você consegue reprogramar o seu
inconsciente
eu tenho um cliente que ela foi muito
criativa ela falou poxa mariana eu vou
esquecer nem creme derruba consegue
passar todo dia como que eu vou
conseguir reprogramar minha mente e o
que ela fez ela comprou uma pasta de
dente bem grande que ela calculou que
durariam os três meses colocou uma
estrela na pasta de dente e todas as
manhãs quando ela escovar o dente ela
olhava no espelho e ela verbaliza vá eu
sou meu corpo físico ideal eu sou um ímã
para o meu parceiro ideal eu sou
próspera e durante ao final antes desses
três meses
o milagre tinha acontecido na vida dela
a vida dela realmente tinha se
transformado então plante seu jardim com
a mesma segurança que o agricultor
semeia sua planta no chão o agricultor
ele não tem dúvida ele acredita no
princípio da criação ele acredita no
princípio da vida
se você começar a acreditar no
funcionamento da sua mente você também
colherá novos frutos
a terceira grande dica de creche
eu sou o eu sou é afirmação mais
criativa do universo quando você fala eu
sou você ativa todo o princípio divino
que há dentro de você
então é cuidado com o que você preenche
essa frase se você fala eu sou feia eu
sou gorda eu sou encalhada eu sou lenta
eu sou em lei
aí você já começar a imaginar na mente
de vocês o tanto que eu sou que às vezes
a gente fala na verdade
substitua automaticamente e se eu sou
por palavras elevadas
quando você fala eu sou e você sente a
vibração disso você muda sua fisiologia
você muda a energia do seu corpo
greg prendem que é um outro super
estudioso da mente humana ele nos dá o
pulo do gato
ele fala que não é só você fica a regra
é programando como um computador eu sou
você tem que buscar o sentimento por
exemplo se eu quero um companheiro e eu
falo a rã
eu sou amada mas eu não sinto aquilo
universo não cria mas se eu pensasse
como eu me sentiria sendo amada como
seria minha postura corporal como eu
sairia de casa é esse sentimento que vai
colapsar com a sua realidade
dessa maneira você vai estar ajudando o
seu subconsciente a manifestar ea criar
o seu desejo
eu sou faça uma lista
visualize você no seu eu sou ideal e
coloque todas as qualidades que você
gostaria e faça isso repetidas vezes
se você quer ter um bom resultado na
academia 11 incluindo uma vez por mês
você vai conseguir o resultado
é a mesma coisa com os nossos exercícios
mentais para que eu consiga ter
resultado eu preciso repetir repetir
repetir repetir fazer com frequência e
isso vai criar a minha nova realidade
a terceira dica foi a terceira a gente
não a primeira
a primeira foi a saída da unidade
a segunda foi a questão lembrando está
escutando estão conscientes
a segunda foi o qual foi a segunda
reverter situações negativas em
positivas certo a terceira decretada ao
eu sou
vocês não estão despertos não estão
conscientes ea quarta fazer
visualizações a este me contou que a
imaginação vai superar o conhecimento
porque o que a imaginação é limitada mas
o conhecimento ele dá uma volta ao mundo
o conhecimento é o a imaginação ela é
como se fosse os olhos da nossa alma
quando você imagina e traz um sentimento
para cá
a imaginação você também cria a sua
realidade nada do que a gente está vendo
aqui tudo que a gente está vendo aqui
foi antes criado na mente de alguém
a dica que eu vou dar pra vocês é ao
dormir
outra dica que o josé sua fala ele falou
o seguinte que quando você está a melhor
hora para fazer essas visualizações e
essas afirmações
é quando você está num estado de
relaxamento profundo
então preste atenção como é que você vai
pra cama como são seus hábitos se você
vai pra cama com um computador você vai
pra cama com a televisão ligada e eu vou
fazer um desafio pra vocês que é ao
dormir tomar banho
desligue os aparelhos bem na sua cama
refazer seu dia de tudo o que você tem
para agradecer durante o dia e quando
você tiver em relaxar um relaxamento já
tiver bastante relaxado
você vai projetar na sua tela mental a
que a gente tem o chakra da testa o agni
chacra a águia em san siro sânscrito
significa comando ordem e você vai
projetar na sua tela mental como se
fosse uma tela de cinema e você vai se
ver ali como se você fosse o diretor da
sua história como se você fosse um
personagem principal da sua história e
você vai colocar ali todos os seus
decretos do eu sou você vai responder
àquelas perguntas que eu fiz no começo
eu sou feliz no amor
eu sou próspero eu já passei a minha
liberdade financeira mas você não vai
pedir você vai comandar com frases
curtas e afirmativas
eu sou próspero eu sou saudável eu sua
cura eu sou cada vez melhor
eu sou um ímã para o dinheiro eu atraio
relacionamento e troca as verdadeiras e
senti busca o sentimento buscar emoção
daquilo torne tão real como se você
realmente tivesse ele coloque cor e
luminosidade amplia a imagem na sua tela
mental e você vai ver o que vai
acontecer num prazo de três meses
o milagre realmente vai acontecer porque
porque você é o diretor da sua vida você
é o comandante da sua alma
você é o mestre da sua vida
obrigada
nossa quase trabalho
[Aplausos]